[Music]
in spite of how much you plan
and in spite of how much you prepare
that life has a way of interrupting
and there's no accounting for what life
dishes out for you
and there's only accounting for how you
deal with it
i didn't have a game plan but i always
knew that i wanted to be in the game
so i i didn't know where i would be at
50 i knew
from the beginning at 20 and 25 that
my brother was going to seek public
office and i knew that
wherever he was going to go i was going
to go with him
we've been best friends my whole life he
told me since i was a little girl
that whatever he could do he said i
could do better
so he said come on val we've got places
to go and things to do with people to
see and off we went
and i've managed his campaigns and
uh you know for seven consecutive senate
races and then the two bids for the
presidency so i've
i've been with them all along and it was
only after 50
that i started to go on side journeys or
adventures of my own
so i got a real job outside the family
and i worked for 20 years with a man
named joe slade white who is a
political media consultant and i worked
on democratic campaigns throughout the
country with candidates
preparing their messaging and strategy i
signed up with a women's campaign
international what we did is we
trained women in emerging democracies
how to get a seat at the table
the political table and it's only when
you consider the political table
can then you dictate your economic
freedom and what you can do
and then the john kennedy institute at
harvard and i wrote and
taught a course on politics up close and
personal i mean
i went and i gave an address at harvard
and
my opening remark was you know
my brother's vice president he was at
the time
and my dad and mom were really proud of
that
you know and my dad would say you know
go champ
but dad i'm here addressing the women
at harvard law school and my dad would
say
that's my girl i mean and it was i mean
our daughter was the first person we
ever knew who went to harvard so it was
a big deal
you know if you do the right things at
the right time for the right reasons
the real stumbling block is it always
doesn't come out
the right way that you thought that it
should
and uh life just has a way of unfolding
so
you you just have to be open
serendipity plays such a greater role
in our lives than we would ever figure
so i got the plan i've got the purpose
i've got the education i'm going for
this
and then life interrupts but
serendipity is our friend if you're just
open and say hmm never thought of that
and sometimes we wouldn't get them never
thought of that
unless we got cracked on the head and we
were you know forced to think oh geez
so i that's what i when i speak to the
young students
what's your advice and i said you know
be focused that's great educate yourself
be focused but be open
you